je vais donc vous l'aurez dire pour vous
cameron je peux aussi être un homme qui
tombe amoureux de la mauvaise personne
il arrive parfois de tomber amoureux de
la mauvaise personne tombé amoureux de
la mauvaise personne c'est en faisant
des heures
j'ai passé cette année c'est tout ce qui
est arrivé il ressent et je suis
impatiente pour révéler à tous mon
nouveau mois
il ya un énorme souci avec le protecteur
[Musique]
il en train de devenir complètement taré
au hameau
bouturez salut toi on raconte partout
que tu te tient à carreau de piano
et à l'école n'est massacre de super
nous paraît même que tu as beyayo
campbell sans chercher à l'étrangler là
je le trouve un peu sadiques peut-être
qu'en soirée c'est exagéré
si les gens veulent des super pouvoirs
le véritable pouvoir ce n'est pas ceux
ci
c'est la capacité de plier les autres à
votre volonté
je sais pourquoi tu as fait ça je
pensais pouvoir combattre va autres
légalement mais c'est pas possible faut
le faire à ta manière
c'est à nous de décider on n'est plus
contre raj est un très important
j'en arrive avec la main sur cette âme
on pourra choquer le protecteur exploser
sa [ __ ] en servez
c'est quoi ça dû composer vais
temporaire vous allez avoir besoin de ce
truc
[Musique]
tout notre démarche c'est de combattre
l'idée même des super pouvoirs
pour une fois je pouvais jouer avec les
mêmes cartes
j'ai montré aux gens
ce que j'étais vraiment
les gens même d'abord un
mr
merde le petit soldat